thouars qui font partie des grandes
atteint de la république ira la parole
et à monsieur jt pour le groupe l'est
républicain virer la parole merci madame
président en tête j'associe alors mon
collègue dino cinieri ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
écoutez nos agriculteurs ils souffrent
ils sont pas entendus ils sont mal
considéré par votre gouvernement
il traverse une crise profonde et
structurelle une crise qui va durer
monsieur le premier ministre
écoutez nos agriculteurs ministre de
l'agriculture n'entend pas la détresse
de nos paysans il est absent il n'a
aucun poids à bruxelles ils fuient même
les salons agricoles
vos réponses sont totalement
insuffisantes
monsieur le premier ministre écoutez nos
agriculteurs ils ne vivent plus de leur
travail
il y a urgence à prendre des mesures qui
répondent aux problèmes de fond nous
devons leur donner des perspectives
redonner de la compétitivité à nos
agriculteurs
arrêtez de les assommer de charges
arrêté l'inflation et la sueur
transposition des normes obtenez la
garantie des prix rémunérateurs
monsieur le premier ministre nos paysans
sont à bout de souffle
quand allez-vous prendre le taureau par
les cornes et redonner un avenir à nos
agriculteurs
merci
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt sur le
député avait interrogé et a fait et fait
même quelques commentaires sur ma
présence cet été où mon absence je ne
sais pas ce que vous avez fait cet été
mais moi je sais ce que j'ai fait vous
avez évoqué des questions structurelles
monsieur le député je voudrais vous
rappeler de manière très claire que s'il
ya des questions structurelles qui sont
posés à l'agriculture aujourd'hui on les
doit en grande partie à cause de vous
jamais on vous attendu ni entendu sur
les grands jeunes qui ont été engagées
que ça soit les européennes avec une
bonne santé en 2008 la fin des quotas
laitiers et qui nous met dans la
situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui jamais monsieur le député on
vous a entendu critiquer une loi lme que
vous avez voté avec bolland et qui
aujourd'hui conduit à la situation que
nous connaissons sur les prix agricoles
jamais monsieur le bit et nous vous
avons attendu au moment du grenelle de
l'environnement penser à cela c'est à la
sueur transposition des normes et
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes le relais des
agriculteurs alors que jamais depuis que
nous sommes arrivés nous avons sur
transports-- sûr transposer des normes
environnementales à l'agriculture alors
monsieur le député dans ce débat où la
détresse ou la détresse des agriculteurs
est réelle il faudrait au moins qu'on
est tous la conscience de l'intérêt
général
la capacité à 11 semble à préparer
l'avenir et l'avenir ils se prennent au
jeu
cette crise il faut la traiter
conjoncturellement avec des aides à la
fois l'échelle européenne et à l'échelle
nationale et en même temps posé les
bases qui permettront à l'ensemble des
filières de tuer ce que m'a fait les
moyens de contractualiser avec la grande
distribution l'industrie afin que les
producteurs soit enfin rémunéré du
travail qu'ils font voilà monsieur le
député quels sont les enjeux et surtout
de gratte pas deux
polémique didot commentaires comme vous
l'avez fait le travail et continue et
hier j'étais à luxembourg et
contrairement à ce que dit la france
paie est là et qu'elle a obtenu beaucoup
de ce conseil
elle confiera